what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today I want to try something
new I truly believe that anime along
with other forms of art can teach us
important life lessons that can help us
live better lives so for this video I'll
go over ten life lessons from attack on
Titan if you like the idea of this
series then leave a like and I'll do the
same for other anime as well now I'm not
necessarily saying that I didn't know
any of these lessons or truths before
watching attack on Titan I probably did
but the beauty of good art is that it
can knock us out of our autopilot day to
day existence and remind us about what's
really important even if we know certain
things logically we forget and require
regular reminders to put us back on the
right track these reminders can come in
many forms like through anime or even
through this YouTube video that's the
hope anyway if you are interested insult
development and the idea of becoming the
best version of yourself definitely
check out the podcast episodes on our
other youtube channel project uproar
where we talk about different ways we've
improved our lives every week my brother
animatic and I even talked about our
journey on YouTube and how we became
professional youtubers in one episode
link to that is in the description and
I'll pin a comment to that channel too I
regularly mentioned different anime that
inspired me on the podcast so you can
look forward to that too now sit back
relax and think over these life lessons
from attack on Titan keep in mind there
will be some spoilers in this video
you've been warned
lesson number one life is unpredictable
and can be snatched away at any moment
the only predictable thing is that
things will change at one point before
he saved Mikasa and the colossal Titan
attack Eren had a pretty boring carefree
life he hung out by the water with Armin
and wish that something would happen he
had all his basic needs met he had
parents who loved him and a friend to
play with later his quiet boring life
disappears forever when the colossal
Titan attacks Aaron's mother is eaten
before his eyes by the smiling Titan
Eren eats his dad and gains the ability
to become one of the monsters he hates
so much all of a sudden that safe boring
world that he took for granted before
starts to seem pretty idyllic just like
they did for Eren things can change at
any moment perhaps no one's going to get
eaten by Titans but there are illnesses
car accidents natural disasters and so
on in the real world that can affect us
or the ones we love we should keep in
mind that things can change at any
moment don't take what you have today
for granted because it could be gone
tomorrow
be grateful keep in mind your own
mortality and the mortality of those you
love and that will help you keep things
in perspective if you knew you had a
month to live would you stress out over
that exam or essay the stoic philosopher
Seneca wrote let us prepare our minds as
if we'd come to the very end of life let
us postpone nothing we should live life
like this to start putting into practice
that dream you've always been postponing
start spending quality time with your
parents because they won't be around
forever and neither will you
the Titans are at the gates you're
getting closer to death with each
passing second make each today count
lesson number two there's always another
side to the story in her famous novel
Wide Sargasso Sea Jean Rhys takes the
mad woman in the Attic from Charlotte
brontë's Jane Eyre and tells her story
and in doing so she humanizes an
otherwise devilish character in this
novel the main character Antoinette says
there's always the other side always
this fact holds true for attack on Titan
as well for a long time we think that
the Titans are humanity's enemy then we
figure out that Titans used to be LD in
people who were turned into mindless
Titans against their will
they're victims of a cruel and unjust
world and the last thing they wanted to
do was eat the people they were trying
to free from oppression Reiner seems to
be a clear villain at one point but then
we get his story we find out that he was
brainwashed from a young age to believe
that the island dwelling LD ins were
Devils what he's doing he's doing for
his family he attacked the island and
killed innocent people just like Aaron
later attacked Marley and killed
innocent people in Marley Reiner is the
hero and Aaron is the villain even
though they're both just humans doing
what they think is right there are
countless other examples but you get the
point
even if someone appears to be a clear
villain he is a hero to someone maybe to
himself to his family or to his nation
it all depends on how you
at the situation this applies to our own
world as well when countries are at war
people from one side tend to demonize
the other side and vice versa
even on a micro level if you think
someone is being a jerk to you remember
that you don't know what he or she is
going through often we spread negativity
when we're in a negative place ourselves
feel pity for people who are always
negative and insulting and don't take it
personally because it's not about you
it's about them lesson number three
history is constructed there's an
especially illuminating quote from
George Orwell's dystopian novel 1984 it
goes like this those who control the
present control the past and those who
control the past control the future
in other words history is written by the
victors we see this process at work in
attack on Titan the nation of Marlay
rewrote history after they won the great
titan war so that the LD ins were
portrayed as Devils while the Marlins
were portrayed as great and merciful
similarly in the walls the history books
are written to perpetuate the belief
that no humans are left beyond the walls
only Titans in both cases history is
written in such a way that will serve
the people in power and their wishes we
must keep this in mind as well never
mistake history textbooks for objective
truth be like Erlin be a critical
thinker lesson number four monsters do
exist but they're human in attack on
Titan the Titans seem like the monsters
at first and it's not a coincidence that
they turn out to be humans the monsters
were always humans are miss Paris
weren't killed by Titans from outside
the walls but by the humans within the
walls the mindless Titans didn't break
into the walls it was human Titan
shifters the mindless Titans didn't
choose to become Titans Malayan officers
turned them into Titans perhaps the
closest thing to a pure monster is the
male an officer gross who has fun
watching el Diaz get killed
he killed grisha's innocent little
sister when he wasn't required to in
fact he broke marlane rules to do it yet
even he loves his sons and tenses up at
the thought of anything happening to
them
attack on Titan teaches us that monsters
are humans and humans can become
monsters what usually turns them into
monsters is adherence to an ideology
that positions
human beings as less human gross feels
justified in his actions because he
believes Aldean's are monsters in human
skin in his mind gross is not killing
humans he's killing the monsters that
might have one day killed him and the
people he cares about
similar patterns of thought were
prevalent during World War two we must
always be wary of any ideology or
narrative that positions other human
beings as less than human
ironically the belief that others are
less than human leads the believer to
take inhumane actions themselves lesson
number five the right decision isn't
always obvious it's easy to say do the
right thing but the right thing isn't
always obvious like when Levi chose to
bring back Armin and let Erlin rest
Aaron wanted that while Hans II would
have chosen to bring back Erwin will
often be in situations like that where
the answer is not clear
Levi tells Aaron at one point no one
ever knows how it will turn out so
choose for yourself whichever decision
you will regret the least since we don't
know how things will turn out we have to
make what we believe is the best
decision in the moment and maybe it will
be the wrong decision but hopefully we
can learn from it and do better in the
future lesson number six everyone loses
in a war on paper you will likely have
the winner of a war and the loser of a
war however the truth is all sides
suffer in attack on titan eren lost his
mother when male attacked his hometown
similarly Gabby lost her friends Udo and
Sophia went Eren attacked Marlay no
matter who wins this war Aaron will
never get his mother back and Gabby will
never get her friends back sometimes war
is a necessary evil but we should never
forget that everyone loses in a war
lesson number seven life can be unfair
but try to do your best with the cards
you're dealt the belief that life will
or even could always be fair is just not
realistic things will happen that
devastate you just as Aaron suddenly
lost his mother father and childhood in
one day so - could you go through an
excruciating loss Aaron along with most
LD ins likely wishes that
ian's were free were discriminated
against and weren't viewed by other
humans as subhuman monsters but that's
not the case so what he decides to do is
use his Titan powers and influence to
try and create the world he wishes for
sidenote I don't believe he actually
plans to carry out Zeke's crazy use in
Asia plan anyways like an attack on
Titan real life is not always going to
seem fair but we have two options we can
complain about how unfair it is or we
can try to do something about it using
the things we do have going for us and
often struggle and pain can make us
stronger people who are capable of
accomplishing even greater things lesson
number eight the importance of not
giving up even when things seem hopeless
there were many times in attack on Titan
when things seemed hopeless many people
thought that there was no use for a
survey core the Titans seemed to post
too much of a threat and it seemed like
they could never be defeated by people
for a long time the survey Corps just
lost men and then lost territory to the
Titans they could have just given up but
as the saying goes nothing ventured
nothing gained if you hope to change
things you have to take action and keep
trying without giving up no matter how
impossible your goals seemed at the
moment eventually the survey corps is
rewarded for their continued effort they
managed to take back wall Maria and she
got in a district they managed to kill
most of the Titans on the island that
threatened their existence and then they
managed to make connections with people
from the outside world who can help them
advance their military technology in the
hopes that they won't just be sitting
ducks when the rest of the world comes
to destroy them thanks to the continuous
efforts of the men and women of the
survey Corps the LD ins on the island
have a chance to survive and even thrive
however if they gave up it would have
been impossible for them to fight Titans
or the world Levi's along with other
skilled fighters would have never got
his hands on vertical maneuvering gear
if the survey Corps disbanded which
would mean that any invading Marlin
Titan shifters would have had an easy
time conquering humanity within the
walls of course the survey Corps is not
out of the Titan forest yet but they
never would have accomplished so much
and come so far
if they had given up and listen to the
naysayers when my brother Anna Mack and
I were starting out as youtubers many
people laughed at the idea of making a
living from it and said it couldn't be
done that we were just wasting our time
and effort and for a long time we
couldn't make a living off of it we
didn't give up though and eventually we
managed to make YouTube our full-time
job of course we also aren't out of the
pine forest yet you never know what
could happen in the future with ad
pocalypse 'as unfair copyright strikes
and so on but we've already done better
than most people thought possible and at
this point the possibilities seem
endless while some people saw a lost
cause we believed that it was possible
and didn't give up and we were rewarded
for that perseverance as with the survey
Corps there isn't a guarantee that
you'll succeed in the long run but if
you keep getting back on that horse
there's always still a chance that you
might however as soon as you start
believing the naysayers or haters or
whatever you want to call them and you
give up that chance drops to zero and as
Jim Carrey once said you can fail at
what you don't want so you might as well
take a chance at doing what you love
lesson number 9 the importance of
teamwork in attack on Titan everyone has
different abilities that come in handy
in different ways together characters
can accomplish incredible things that
they could never hope to accomplish on
their own let's take a look at one
instance where Arman and Aaron faced off
against the colossal Titan often
referred to as the god of destruction
the colossal Titan seems unbeatable he's
tall
powerful and can release steam that will
burn anyone who gets close to it however
Arman and Aaron managed to work together
in order to defeat him Arman comes up
with the plan Aaron in Titan form takes
a fall he acts like he is in no shape to
fight anymore and then uses his harding
titan powers to create a fake titan so
that when aaron sneaks out of the titan
body
Berthold still thinks he's far away and
not a threat to him Arman distracts
Berthold by almost getting himself
burned to death and then when Berthold
stops the steam Aaron who has snuck
behind him cuts him out of the colossal
Titans mate this is just one of many
cases where teamwork made the impossible
possible if you want to accomplish
truly
great things of life seemingly
impossible things you need to accept the
fact that you'll need help from others
to do it even on this channel it is only
possible for us to release as many
videos as we do because of our team
which includes me and my brother are
hardworking editors our patrons over on
patreon our sponsors and you without
subscribers like you we wouldn't be able
to do any of this so thank you for being
a part of this na kama anime uproar is
definitely a product of teamwork and
without it we would never have gotten
this far
lesson number 10 the importance of
freedom freedom is a recurring subject
in attack on Titan in fact the attack
Titan the power that the show is named
after is all about freedom both Grisha
and our protagonist Eren found
themselves trapped within walls and they
wanted to escape they both inherited the
attack Titan power which according to
Aaron Krueger has always moved ahead
seeking freedom it has fought on for
freedom even the survey Corps insignia
is known as the wings of freedom there's
this constant tension revolving around
whether people should risk everything to
be free like Krrish and Aaron were
willing to do or live a quote-unquote
safe isolated life inside closed walls
like cattle grisha's parents and even
Aaron's mother seem to prefer the latter
option to the former the situation
within the walls is very similar to
Plato's allegory of the cave in Plato's
example people have spent their lives
chained in a cave looking at a blank
wall people see shadows on the walls and
mistake these illusions for reality the
philosopher is one who escapes the
chains makes his way out of the cave and
realizes that the world of shadows was
just an illusion his goal is to take
other people out of the cave but most
people are comfortable with the shadows
and their illusions since that's the
only reality they've ever known
the prisoners fear the unknown and do
not desire to leave their prison in
matrix terms the philosopher takes the
red pill while the others take the blue
pill and they often get hostile when
their vision of reality is brought into
question this was the case with the
walls many people want to stay inside
believing there was no hope or future
for Humanity outside them they wanted to
believe
the reality they'd been fed ever since
they were born that they were the last
remnants of humanity however some people
refused to simply adopt this illusion
they questioned it like a winded errand
was the same he wanted to be free
venture outside the walls and that is
how he managed to find out what was in
the basement that's when the survey
Corps realized that the history they
were told was a sham and that life goes
on beyond the walls and beyond the
island the truth isn't always easy to
deal with
for instance they found out that the
Titans they were killing with a
vengeance were actually fellow LD ins
who were turned into mindless Titans
against their will however like the
attack Titan our characters keep moving
seeking truth and freedom anyways in
life - we've all been brought up to
believe certain things that aren't
actually true for instance the quote
unquote safe choice is not always safe
you can fail or get fired from a
traditionally safe job just like the LD
ins who kept making the safe decision of
never moving beyond the walls would have
had the invaders destroy them eventually
we may not have literal chains or walls
trapping us in place but there's no
shortage of mental walls and chains in
this world we have to free ourselves
from the false narratives we were fed
since we were kids like that the key to
life is a well-paying safe job in
abundance of materialistic things like
big cars and houses some people may
think you're crazy if you give up a
cushy office job that pays well to start
your own business some people may think
minimalists are crazy for downgrading
their house car and purposely giving up
many modern luxuries so that they have
more time to pursue what they love
however freedom is when you stop letting
what other people think
dictate your life and you start doing
what you truly want to do even if it is
risky and seems crazy to others
philosophers members of the survey corps
people who take the red pill all of them
have one thing in common they prioritize
a free man's risky life to a prisoners
false sense of security as with Aaron a
free life for me is and will always be a
thing worth pursuing this is why I say
I'm an aspiring Pirate King in my
personal Instagram profile I really
resonate with Luffy's go
of becoming the freest man in the world
and that is it for today's video
this one was quite the journey let me
know if you guys like this format for
videos
do you like self-development do you have
any suggestions for other inspirational
anime I should watch that is jam-packed
with life lessons let me know if you
enjoyed this video make sure to smash
that like button if you haven't be sure
to subscribe and hit that notification
about so you know when new videos drop
if you are interested in
self-development and becoming the best
version of yourself definitely check out
the podcast episodes on our YouTube
channel project uproar where we talk
about different ways we've improved our
lives every week linked in the
description and they'll pin a comment to
that channel to a big thank you goes out
to our patrons over on patreon who help
make these videos possible I especially
want to thank our pro hero tier patrons
the one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a
fan Jason Wilson and Kings eldress and
are the one tier patrons the ones who
stand atop all clans a17 FF DP Steven
and Radha Maddy Mac 239 and makoto-kun
and the extremely special patron whose
greatness transcends this plane
altogether Regan Harrison the one who
has been acknowledged by Lorde we go
sent by sama himself if you enjoy our
work you can support more of it by going
over to patreon Kong anime uproar and
becoming a patron today for as little as
$1 if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord
so check out patreon.com/lenguin
if you're interested anyways thanks
again for all your support and until
next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]